hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive in the next
half hour we'll see what's making the
headlines with the director of
communications at the institute of
economic affairs annabelle denham and
the political correspondent for the
financial times at laura hughes uh well
let's have a look at what's on some of
those front pages uh the daily telegraph
leads with ukraine its headline the pm
urges russia to step back from brink uh
the express uses this same quote in its
headline to look at what they're calling
the prime minister's diplomatic dash to
europe
schultz plans fresh ukraine talks as
west steps up evacuations is on the
front of the financial times
as they look at germany's response to
the crisis the metro also leads with
this story its headline west kant
vladiscare putin
in other news the national quotes ian
blackford who describes boris johnson's
imminent trip to scotland as a farewell
tour and the guardian looks at calls for
radical action after a race report into
britain's public health service
finds gross failings in the nhs and a
reminder that by scanning the qr code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's papers uh while you watch us
uh we're joined as i said tonight by
animal denim and laura hughes let's get
straight into the papers good evening to
you both thanks for being with us
um i want to start with the ft and on
its front page schultz plans fresh
ukraine talks as wes steps up
evacuations
one line here that i picked out this
coming from the german chancellor i
don't assume will come out of this with
some kind of concrete result he said but
he insisted that now is not the time uh
for resignation um i wonder uh laura if
you think that sort of sums up the
situation in that there is this
desperate attempt for diplomacy without
much hope that it's going to break
through
yeah i think that's fair and also
the point of worth making is that
germany of course is really reliant on
russia in terms of the energy it gets
and there has been some criticism in
whitehall from british diplomats that
maybe the french in particular and
slightly the germans have been a little
bit more
softly spoken in their dealings with the
russians
but of course germany i think tomorrow
is going to try and step up the rhetoric
and play hardball
given the situation and given the fact
that you have seen this massive
diplomatic blitz from the americans the
brits the french everyone basically
trying to talk putin
down the ladder and this is just the
latest attempt really and i think it
reflects how deeply concerned
european allies and nato are about putin
and his um ambitions deeply concerned
and until now not looking very united in
their reaction to uh this crisis
annabelle the daily telegraph has on its
front page so pm urges russia to step
back from the brink is the the headline
uh with johnson of course beginning this
this last-ditch round of diplomacy as
they call it um they quote a russian
ambassador saying and i can't actually
say the word so i'll say we don't give a
bleep about sanctions is
what he says i wonder if i mean is that
the issue here is that it doesn't really
matter what the west does now in terms
of sanctions it's not going to be enough
to deter uh putin if he does want to
invade which of course we don't know if
he does
yes absolutely i think that ukraine has
always been of greater geopolitical
significance to russia than it has to
the western alliance and this is the
corner that the west have backed
themselves into we are entering into a
fight and we're not really willing to
follow through i mean all of the front
pages really are underscoring the
immense amount of uncertainty with the
situation in ukraine we still don't know
what's going to happen there's still a
strong sense as there has been for many
weeks that the coming days are critical
we're going to see more saber rattling
we're going to see more um rhetoric
perhaps with expletives perhaps not more
efforts at diplomacy
parties backing themselves into ever
tighter corners and and you know in my
view it'll just become ever clearer that
the only realistic option for uh the
west for nato for europe uh for the uk
and the u.s um
are our economic sanctions and we can
impose pretty severe financial sanctions
on russia
but
there's a risk that either they backfire
and they have implications for our own
economies uh or they push russia towards
uh an invasion so you know we're
treading on very thin ice here we simply
don't know what's going to happen where
a couple of weeks ago i might have said
that there was about a 50 50 chance
of an incursion i think that's increased
in the last fortnight or so i think
we're probably looking at close to a
probability of two to one but uh don't
don't don't hold me to that let's see
what happens yeah it's hard to hold hard
to hold anyone to any of these
predictions at the moment laura i wonder
if you stick your neck out and make a
prediction uh like that bearing in mind
for example that on the front page of
the guardian leave now western diplomats
flee kiev
this idea that the u.s and the uk
certainly are removing their diplomatic
staff i mean does that suggest an
invasion is more likely now
i think what that reflects is that we're
only six months since kabul and the
evacuation there and i don't think
anybody expected afghanistan to fall to
the taliban as quickly as it did and
that was an incredibly humiliating
moment i think overall putin saw what
happened in afghanistan
saw what he perceived to be
the western's disinterest in engaging in
foreign conflict or overseas affairs and
has potentially sought to exploit that
so i think the
the urgency with which we are
withdrawing our diplomats from ukraine
reflects the fact that we're sharing a
lot of intelligence with the americans
we're very much aligned with them i
think the brits are seeing this whole
crisis as an opportunity to show
the us president biden that we are
still
his number one ally in europe i think
before he came in he thought macron
might be
so i think it reflects
us wanting to do what the other the
americans do
and also just a worry of any sort of
repetition
from uh what we saw happen in
afghanistan and kabul and the observer
sort of touches on that on their front
page going into
tomorrow um
it's so hard to know i think you know
the americans are clear that something
could happen within a couple of days
but truly nobody knows and there was a
very interesting tweet from the russian
embassy i saw
um in the last 24 hours where they
suggested that if they were to back down
the west would seize it as a diplomatic
victory and it would be spun
back here as a massive success which i
thought was interesting were they
hinting that maybe they were prepared to
take a step back the honest truth is
nobody knows and everybody's incredibly
nervous and very worried and
watching and i think there's a sense
that it's better just to get people out
in case something goes wrong but also
it's been really interesting to look at
different media outlets talking to
people actually living in ukraine over
the weekend who are many of whom are
going about their their business as
normal and who don't feel any need to
panic and i think some of the ukrainian
politicians have also suggested everyone
is being a little bit too hysterical and
needs to not panic because that's just
provoking the russians but honestly it's
hard to say clearly western intelligence
is such that there are real fears
something could happen within the next
few days and it is you touched on it
there but it is always very interesting
to see uh how this is being reported by
the russian media certainly because we
talk about it in one sense but there is
of course the russian side of this story
uh we're moving away from ukraine now
we're going to look at a few other
stories certainly closer to home let's
start with the national the scottish
paper and laura one for you here pm's
visit a farewell tour says uh ian
blackford uh a walking advert for indy
this all part of the prime minister's uh
tour around the uk trying to sell his
leveling up agenda and and hopefully
just distract from the partygate uh
stuff that's going on at home
given what ian blackford's saying there
does that just show the scale of the
task he has ahead of
him yes and i think it's not a
coincidence that one of the first places
he would go during parliamentary recess
is scotland because the union is in
real trouble according to those sort of
around boris johnson at the moment they
know that they have a huge problem
one glaring one is the fact that the
conservative leader douglas ross has
actually called for the prime minister
to resign in recent weeks over the party
gate allegations so that's deeply
embarrassing
for boris johnson and like i think
reports have said that he will be
avoiding
the scottish tory leader which is again
very very bizarre and we had jacob
rees-mogg the former leader of the
commons um
dismissing douglas ross as a sort of
insignificant figure which again
was really uncomfortable and angered a
lot of backbench tory mps who are deeply
concerned that the the scottish
population are becoming increasingly
alienated with the government in london
and ian black said they're talking about
another vote of independence another
opportunity or chance or calls to break
away
from england and um he's going to have
quite a big task on his hands and
yeah i don't know whether it is easier
to to go on this tour of europe and try
and
dissuade russia from invading ukraine
because he really does have his own
battlefront back home that he's going to
have to deal with yes certainly and i
wonder annabelle what you make of of
with this new uh plan from the
government they're talking about their
slim down you know trying to reduce the
size of uh government
trying to obviously move the focus from
the crises that they've been jumping
between to actually
the job that they're there to do which
is to govern the country uh do you like
the plan
um well anything that that slims down
the size of the government uh gets my
support for sure i mean in terms of this
story obviously we've got to bear in
mind that it is in the scottish
national um what's interesting is how
incense the scottish people still are
about partygate one poll and the article
found that more than three quarters of
scots think that boris johnson should
resign while just 15
think he should stay
obviously he's got a serious problem
with the leader of the scottish
conservatives and he's going to have to
go to scotland and embark on a strategy
of appeasement there but i think when it
comes to taking on the smp uh boris
johnson has got to go on the offensive
he's got to remind the scottish people
about uh the snp's performance on the
economy on covid on civil liberties on
education all those uh areas where in my
view at least the snp has
been left wanting um so you know
obviously it's going to be a very
challenging week arguably the prime
minister would be on more comfortable
territory believe it or not negotiating
and um engaging in diplomacy with uh the
situation in ukraine more than going to
scotland and trying to face uh the
scottish people and put forward his
leveling up agenda to them but it it's
going to be a challenging week for him
one way or the other but i do think it's
it's very important that he goes uh to
scotland and starts to try and rally
support there
i want to quickly try and squeeze in one
more uh story here from the front the
front page of the financial times
shoppers undeterred as big brands raise
prices to protect profits from rising
costs this is companies like pepsico
mcdonald's kellogg's they're all passing
on their input costs to us
very very quickly annabelle how serious
is this
well i mean look this story is just
going to keep running and running and
here we've got these major brands
household brands that are raising prices
to deal with higher labor shipping and
commodity costs we knew that this was
coming down the line some people will be
cushioned from it at least in the short
term by pandemic savings and to a degree
will continue to be cushioned by the
fact that they're working from home
they're not spending money on commuting
or in town
the majority who are not working from
home will will really struggle i'm so
sorry to have to cut you off